[Music]
the jacksonville jaguars have franchise
tagged past russia yannick and gawkway
and they are drawing interest from
multiple teams according to mike
gerfollo of nfl media
but the jaguars are waiting for the
right return that prompted ngakway to go
to twitter and say let's agree to
disagree why hold a man from taking care
of his family it's obvious my time is up
in my current situation let's both move
on at jaguars with the checkered flag
although the checkered flags at the end
i guess he means it's the end of the
relationship between the jaguars and
ngaku look the bottom line is the
jaguars played this game last year and
they got two first round picks and a
fourth round pick for jaylen ramsey drag
your feet slow play it wait and
ultimately you call the ball when the
best offer comes in last year frank
clark netted a first round pick and a
second round pick for the seahawks when
they traded him to the chiefs d ford got
a second round pick for the chiefs when
they traded into the 49ers so i just
think it's a matter of time before
somebody recognizes we're gonna make the
play for yannick and gawkway maybe it
happens after the draft maybe it's after
the first round sometime during the
draft but i feel like it's gonna happen
and since there's no offseason program
there's no urgency here to do anything
chris
i understand yannick wants to know where
he's going next but you know i i feel
like the wheels are in motion for
something to happen where the jaguars do
trade and move on from yannick way yeah
i don't think there's any doubt i mean
when he's starting to
you know he's drawn a line in the sand
basically to say he doesn't want to get
you know he doesn't want to be there so
i don't know how else that could work
you know i don't i know doug marone i
read some of his quotes yesterday i
think he's still holding out an outside
shot that there could be some resolution
here to where they can keep a yannick
and gawk way but i would think
ultimately there's a huge market for
yannick and gawkway and like the jaguars
are saying that there's teams interested
of course there are you know he's he's a
commodity he's a special commodity he's
a better pass rusher to this point of
his career than d ford has been or
demarcus lawrence with the dallas
cowboys so you might not say he's going
to run defenders of demarcus lawrence
but certainly a good pass rusher and
mike i think the other thing that's
going to add you know value to yannick
and gawkway here as far as the the
jaguars trade
is the the draft
at least to where i'm at right now it
doesn't seem like it's real deep with
you know those freaky defensive ends
that we look at to go oh there's going
to be four or five in the top 40 who
could be you know sack machines i i
don't think it's this type of draft
class so that's going to add value to
people wanting to get their hands on
yannick and gawkway as well
who do you think should be making the
move and what do you think is fair is it
the second round pick for ford or is a
one and a two for clark or somewhere in
between yeah somewhere in between you
know i think that's pretty fair i don't
i would say it was probably sec more
than more than just a second round pick
for d4 you know yannick and gawkway
doesn't have an injury history d ford
had that you know so you had to have
that little concern there either way so
you know maybe if it's a team late in
the first round maybe they can get a
late first rounder but i think
ultimately it'll be a second and some
sort and some change to go with it maybe
a second in the third you know maybe a
second and a third and maybe some other
late round pick in next year's draft
something like that uh i i would see it
because again i think it's going to be
hard to ask teams for a first rounder
when a guy has clearly stated he doesn't
want to play on that football team
yeah and the second rounder that brought
d4 to the 49ers was a 2020 second round
or not a 2019. clark was a 2022nd
rounder 2019 first rounder that took him
to the chiefs and look i understand
again why why yannick way is going to
agitate for a trade and really the less
a team has to give up to get him in
trade the more money they may be able to
pay him it's a sliding scale how much do
we give up to get the guy by way of
draft picks how much do we pay him
there's a point where it's too much so
you got to start taking either dollars
or draft picks off the pile to get it to
a point where the balance is just right
so from his perspective the less someone
gives up he may cash in even more and i
think he will cash in with somebody and
look everybody needs pass rushers even
if you have one you need more you
ideally want to have a rotation uh the
question is do you have the money do you
have the draft that you're willing to
part with and do you have the money and
the cap space to make it happen chris
there is so many teams that need a pass
rusher right now
uh that i just would have a hard time
yeah and there's teams that you know
with that money that also have that need
but you know here let me just name off
some teams there where you would go oh
yeah they they could use that guy i mean
first off the seattle seahawks
he would fit that he's played in that
scheme that jaguars run the seattle
scheme that makes sense you know the
miami dolphins you could get into the
bangles the houston texans do they have
a legit pass rusher right now you know
the jets the giants they have nobody on
their front that can come around the
edge and be special that way so the list
goes on and on uh as far as just teams
that can use a guy like janik and goku
coming off the edge he's special that
way he's got a great first step he's
explosive uh so yeah i mean again the
philadelphia eagles i could throw them
in that that mix there there is a lot of
teams with defensive end needs
difference makers coming off the edge
i'd like to see them in silver and black
they're still kind of finding their way
sure the writers come back a couple
years ago
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports